oh my goodness Final Cut Pro is coming
to the iPad this is a day that I never
thought I would actually see coming a
few weeks ago I tweeted about wanting an
update to Final Cut but this was not at
all what I had in mind I basically just
kind of wrote this off as something that
was maybe never going to happen but the
day is here well it's not actually here
yet it'll be out May 23rd when I woke up
and saw the email of the press release
of this iPad Final Cut news I honestly
thought I was dreaming and I had to
double check multiple sources to make
sure that this was information that was
public that was known to everyone is
this actually real Am I Dreaming but my
friends it is as real as real could get
and I actually got a chance to test it
out Hands-On and it was pretty
impressive I didn't really get enough
time to really form a full opinion or do
an actual review we better believe as
soon as I get it I will be diving in and
learning as much as I can I mean just
the few minutes that I was using it it's
incredibly intuitive it is basically
Final Cut reimagined but for the iPad so
there are some new features that they
did announce inside of here so the
entire editing space it's all touch
based you drag and drop you pinch to
zoom there's also this cool thing live
drawing now obviously with the iPad you
can use an apple pencil so it really is
a different style of editing when you
have a touch environment so it is
something that if you're not familiar
with it it will take a little bit of
getting used to but just spending a
short time with it like you're gonna
pick it up very very easily the live
drawing is pretty interesting this gives
you the ability to go in use your apple
pencil draw and then when you go back to
the timeline you'll be able to make this
longer or shorter so if you do need to
stretch that out longer to cover a
bigger chunk of your video you can do
that as well you can obviously edit HDR
there's an iMovie import so if you did
start a project already in iMovie you'll
be able to import that and again apple
pencil and keyboard support the one
thing that was like a big question that
I had was will I be able to to start a
project on my iPad send it to my Mac and
then send it back to my iPad no you will
not be able to send a project back from
your Mac to the iPad so that is one
thing that I feel like if you are
starting a project and you want to send
it to your Mac just know that you're not
going to be able to take it back to the
iPad basically everything is
self-contained inside of the library so
you aren't able to use external drives
so you do have to copy and import any of
the footage onto your iPad so if this is
something that you do plan on doing and
using you definitely will need to have
an iPad that has significant amount of
storage especially if you're editing
larger projects now multicam editing is
also something that you can do in here
and it's so intuitive like it's just I
love using the multicam editor in Final
Cut Pro I use it all the time so here in
the multicam they have three scenes plus
an audio track and with this you'll be
able to solo out the audio track and
then have the video switch in sync with
the audio and inside of the timeline you
you will just click which angle you want
and with that for videos that have
multiple cameras you'll be able to
quickly edit those I just could not do
without multi cam so when I discovered
that it honestly it was pretty
life-changing this isn't something that
it's totally new because you can't do
this in regular Final Cut but it's just
showing the power of the M1 and M2 iPads
to give you this capability of reframing
things for a different frame so if you
have a 16x9 and you want to reframe that
into a vertical for social it makes it
super easy to do that this is also
something that I've tried very quickly
at the end of my demo and then I had to
give the iPad back but this is a scene
removal mask and this is honestly pretty
impressive you'll be able to completely
remove the background and just have your
subjects in frame you'll see in this
demo They removed him from the
background and then placed him into this
background and magically hello you don't
even need a green screen anymore which
is pretty awesome another thing that's
not super new but they did launch this I
don't even remember one it was it was a
little while ago at this point voice
isolation and this is pretty impressive
I use this in almost all of my videos
and you kind of have to find The Sweet
Spot depending upon what type of audio
you're working with this really does
isolate your voice it takes out a lot of
background sound and I love using this
so it's great to see it's also in the
iPad and of course we've got titles
Transitions and effects and you know
some of these are pretty basic I'm not
sure when but I am fingers crossed
hoping that sometime soon they will
offer third-party support with
third-party plugins because I obviously
have my M keynote plug-in that I made
with motion VFX and I use it all the
time and it's kind of like a staple in
my editing is having these plugins and
everything is all custom to my liking
but for a lot of people who are just
getting started and if you just need
basic titles like you have everything
right here at your fingertips they do
have some new themes which is nice
because I feel like if you've been using
Final Cut for a while you have probably
used all of those titles and Transitions
and effects pretty much to death here's
some of the effects I did get a chance
to test this out it was really cool how
fast and effective they all were this is
something cool that they're doing with
music they're able to intelligently
adjust the length of the audio to fit
however long your video is so if you
have like a 10 second video you can drag
the audio to 10 seconds and it'll
automatically fit that but if you have a
longer than that like a 5-10 minute
video you can drag it all the way and it
just kind of reframes itself to make a
perfect seamless audio track which
normally I mean if you're pretty
proficient like it's not that much of a
struggle to kind of loop those but it's
extra at a time that you don't have to
do but with these I'm not sure how many
they said there was a pretty big number
of royalty-free tracks that you would be
able to use in your projects you don't
have to do anything you just drag it
align it to how long you want it to be
and it automatically adjusts they have a
bunch of new Dynamic backgrounds which
you can also customize and of course if
you want to cut yourself out and put
yourself on these backgrounds it's so
easy to do now here it is okay third
party content coming soon it doesn't say
when but this means eventually it'll be
happening so we won't be able to use
plugins so I can't wait for that it's
also pretty cool they have an added Pro
camera mode now so when you go in and
you use your iPad in Pro mode like you
can basically shoot and edit directly
from it it now will give you a focus
feature so you can set your focus it
also has a white balance so you can go
in and change the white balance if you
want it to be different than what the
camera automatically does you'll be able
to edit prores raw and of course you do
have some Advanced coloring features you
are able to shoot in log and edit those
as well and cinematic mode this is kind
of interesting I know this was something
that they had been talking about when
they first launched cinematic mode
editing cinematic mode on the iPad feels
so natural so if you do shoot something
and you want to change the focus in here
it's very very easy to do so you just
basically touch what you want to have
focused and you can also keyframe that
so if you want to do a rack to focus
which is kind of cool it'll give you a
very cinematic look and it's wild what
kind of content you can actually just
shoot on a phone nowadays and here's one
of the screenshots of what it looks like
to export so you're able to change all
of the settings and then we have the
send to Mac and again like I said once
you set it to Mac there's no going back
so don't forget it a lot of the
complaints that I saw this morning was
about the price the fact that they are
making this a subscription a lot of
people are saying well I'm a student I
can't afford that I'm just going to tell
you that I was also a student once and I
literally had no money but I would find
somehow I would find four freaking
dollars to go buy lattes that I could
not afford so when I put it into that
sort of perspective and when I was in
school buying software was
absurdly expensive like Photoshop was
like thousands of dollars and I was just
so grateful because I was in school I
was able to use the school licenses
right now so many things are
subscription based like with Premiere
also subscription based for Photoshop
all of these things I understand where a
lot of you guys are coming from that you
don't want to have to pay another
subscription fee but all things
considered how powerful this is and
depending upon what you're doing with
this most people are probably using this
for production content creation and this
is a small investment into your business
into your creation so for comparison
Final Cut Pro is 300 and compressor is
fifty dollars but that I mean I don't
remember when I bought Final Cut last
like a very long time ago and I've been
continually getting those updates so if
you are buying an M1 or an M2 iPad
you're going to be wanting to use it to
its full potential so if this is
something that you want I mean that's
how much it is I don't know I don't know
what you want me to say like it is what
it is at this point for me like it is a
business expense and from what I've seen
like the app is so good like
skip your Starbucks for the next two two
days and you'll be good to go so as for
iPads it will be on the M1 or the M2 the
fifth or sixth generation iPad Pro the
12.9 or the 11 inch or the iPad Air 5th
gen and it has to be running iPad OS
16.4 or later so that's kind of just a
first look at the Final Cut Pro for the
iPad I have been editing since
2005 on Final Cut so I have seen a lot
and it's really exciting to see it come
to the iPad obviously there are
limitations the fact that you aren't
able to use an external drive that for
me might be limiting because a lot of my
content I do edit off of multiple drives
and I am editing multiple projects at a
time which do have pretty big file sizes
but this is the first iteration of Final
Cut on the iPad so like this is like
we're basically starting from like
version one it is a reimagined version
of Final Cut that we all know and I'm
excited about this because this next
generation of editors which a lot of you
are probably watching this right now you
edit a lot on your phone you edit on the
go you're editing on your iPads on touch
devices editing needs to change I added
a ton on my phone and a lot of things
are shifting that way like watching this
younger generation edit and create you
guys are all editing on touch so this
really is just a natural progression and
as someone who's been editing for so
long I'm excited about it I love to edit
I love to be able to just storytell and
just take a bunch of footage that
otherwise may just be trash and turn it
into something incredible and I think
that's the power of editing the power of
Storytelling and it's really giving back
to people the power to create and tell
whatever story it is that they want to
tell well thank you guys for watching
this was really fun and I'm so excited
to actually get to be able to really
test this out so let me know if you guys
have any questions you can leave them in
the comments below and I will see you
guys in the next video bye
thank you